The jogan Experience dude I'm on the
phone is one of those old ass phones
that are on the
wall the phone I see my dad over there
in the chair my dad's just oldtime
Grizzly wrestler we're living in his
little apartment in Tampa my mom's over
there on the couch and uh I tell the
coach quietly Wally buo is his name
great guy I said hey uh hey thank you
for the opportunity I really appreciate
it but I'm gonna have to close this
chapter in my life and he's like I I
hear him kind of Softly okay yeah I said
so thank you very much I appreciate it
hung up the phone my dad said who was
that I said oh it was a coach from
Calgary he said what do you want oh he
wanted to offer me another contract for
next year by the way the contract was
like I was making 300 bucks a week
Canadian wow so there was no money up
there at least not for me and uh he goes
so when are you gonna go my old man said
this I said I'm
not he said what do you mean you're not
I said I I think I'm done I'm done with
football and the pursuit of it it's just
not in my
cards he said what are you going to do I
said I'm going to get in the business he
went what business I said the wrestling
business dude we got in the biggest
[__] fight really the biggest and he
didn't want you to do it he didn't want
me to do it but my old man was a
groundbreaker your first black tag team
champions in WWE he was jacked pull up
my dad if you can Rocky Johnson I want
to show you like he oh I know your dad
jacked man he he was part of that group
in the early 80s right who were like
bodybuilding and look at that shot damn
there's that's the genetics son that's
it brother that's Rock genetics come
that's it yeah oh my God he was jacked
so yeah and we bonded he used to get me
up and take me to the gym when I was
five sit in the corner and I just that's
how I get to you know really bom my dad
he didn't want me to do it and I we got
into the biggest [__] fight my mom's
crying I'm
crying and he said what do you think you
have to offer I said I don't know maybe
I'm G to [__] suck but I got to give
this a shot and It ultimately it got to
a place where I said either you're going
to help train me I'm asking you to help
train me or I'll I'll go to somebody
else and at that time Brett Hart and
that whole family had his dungeon up in
Calgary I said maybe I'll go to Calgary
he agreed to train me but I realized he
didn't want to see that happen because
he was he felt like hey look around like
I I and I was one of the successful ones
in wrestling but I got a little [__]
apartment that I got to I can't even
afford to pay 500 bucks a month I don't
want this for you so we got into a huge
fight he eventually trained me I call a
guy after three months of training
called a guy named Pat Patterson who was
Vince McMahon's right-hand man very
brilliant mind in the world of pro
wrestling first openly gay wrestler
tough
[__] I call him up cuz my
parents knew knew him and I said hey Pat
this is Dwayne Johnson who Dwayne
Johnson uh Rocky Johnson's son oh yeah
what do you want hey I'm gonna I'm
trying I'm training to get in the
business what [__]
business it's it's a recurring theme
everybody said what [__] business the
wrestling business why the [__] do you
want to do that you're just feeling like
you're just getting bombed right right
left and right by these ogs so I said
I'd love for you to come down and just
watch me train and if I got anything to
offer just let me know and if I don't
just let me know that that's all I want
he agreed he came down watched me train
he said to me as we're training he goes
can you work as a heel which is as you
know bad guy in wrestling parls I said
sure I'd love to we start the match I
work as a heel more aggressive dirty
cheating stuff right um he goes okay
done
done and I trained in a boxing ring and
as you know boxing rings are [__]
hard it's like this right so getting
suplexed on the [__] table so it
really hurt that's how I came up in
wrestling he's smoking a
cigarette I said what do you think do I
have anything he goes um yeah you just
keep
working take care of yourself and leaves
and I was like did I just [__] because
because this he had a lot of he was he
had a lot of power he was like the vice
president of
WWE I said okay well thank you so much
for coming out and I said just just keep
working he goes just keep working kind
of blew me off kept smoking a cigarette
and walked off and I was like man I
think I really [__] things up or maybe
I I'll take his word for face value take
it for gospel I'll just keep working
little I knew he went home and he called
Vince McMahon he said you got to see
this [__] kid and Vince said who
Rocky Johnson's son he goes all right
let me see him bring him out this mon
this Monday on raw and I'll throw him
out in the match before the show starts
whoa Corpus Christie 15,000 people whoa
dude this is your first match first
match oh my God so Vince says to Pat
okay great how long has he been working
he goes he he hasn't worked he goes what
do you mean he's never had a match he's
like he's never had a [__] match I'm
not bringing him out he's never had a
match he's gonna stink up the ring Pat
said just trust me so they fly me out
Corpus
Christie 14,000 people I got and have my
first match and I'm 24 years old wow I
have my first match uh because usually
when you break in you you know you're
wrestling at a farm or there's a barn 10
people 14,000 people I wrestled the
Brooklyn Brawler who's famous in the
world of wrestling and uh I get
backstage everyone's hey great job great
job keep working I see Vince mcmah he
says you did a good job uh but be
prepared I'm going to give you a little
bit more tomorrow I went great okay I
see Pat Patterson smoking a
cigarette come here for a second I said
yeah he goes your punches I went
yeah they [__]
suck just riding me riding me riding me
so that was my first match first
experience man wow yeah and then he he
by the way he said if you're if you have
a shred of opportunity to make it in
this business you're going to have to
learn a lot of [__] but learn how to
throw a great punch what was wrong with
the way you were throwing a punch it it
just didn't look real and the best of
punch es like you got to be snug you lay
them in a little bit you know but you
pull it back a little you pull it well
you can pull it back a little but I
found the best punches is you follow
through but learn how to just tap a
little bit and then you know that's
that's where you learn that kind of
timing you know how some guys they hit a
rope or piece of string or something
like that right so yeah so I worked on
the punches too as well wow that was
crazy that was my first match that's
insane when was the next match uh next
match was the following night whoa so
you were right into it right into it
what's the second match like versus the
first you've already done it you already
been in front of 15,000 people I'm I'm
feeling pretty good because as you know
and like people out there know if you
prepare then all right I'm as prepared
as I possibly can be right so we'll just
see how it goes so the second night I
had a little bit of confidence but the
guy they put me in there with was a guy
named Chris candido incredible wrestler
does a lot of acrobatic stuff flying
stuff he had me he called the match he
had me flying on around and doing all
the stuffs but it was it was a it was a
great experience after that I met with
Vince he said you're not ready for WWE
you're not ready for the big time I'm
going to send you to down to Tennessee
and that's where you're going to learn
how to
work and it was just a smaller company
minor leagues he said but you're going
to go down there you learn how to cut
your teeth down there learn how to work
learn the business and when you're ready
if you're ready I'll bring you up I was
like thank you very much I appreciate it
and I went to work so dude as I'm
leaving Vince McMahon's office he says
hey by the way I turn around he goes
don't go down there and cut your
forehead up with razor
blades I went okay got it because in
wrestling there was a time where that's
how you bled with razor blades and he
and he he goes I want to protect
this so good I do too all
right then years later I'm fuing doing
this up in WWE but that had to be a good
feeling though that had some real real
hope in you that is my second match this
is insane right there look at that this
is
insane
wow does it seem surreal watching this
is so surreal
man look at
this by the
way you see people still coming in right
empty
seats was it wow that was it man first
match memories first match wow that's
crazy it's incredible and then to go
from there to where you became how' to
be
surreal it was the most Sur real thing
because finally when they called me up
to WWE it was November Vince brings me
in and I go to a big pay-per-view called
Survivor Series now the wrestling fans
out know know what this pay-per-view is
it's dece it's uh November
1996 there it is there it
is
dude look at that [__] haircut look
at you Ray Charles cut my hair back then
I was
like wow so this is Madison Square
Garden 22,000 people this is the there's
Jerry The King Lawler the guy's a
legend this is here's a little bit of
watch this there we
go
here's a double Leap Frog here wow drop
kick is coming
up little
punch so even if you see that punch it
was a little shitty punch anyway but
this is so that was Madison Square
Garden sold out Vince McMahon tells me
an hour before I go
out you're gonna win the whole thing
tonight whoa I went what do you mean he
goes you're going to win the whole thing
I'm throwing you right into the fire
I'll never forget this he said you're
either going to [__] sink or you're
going to swim it's New York City it's up
to
you and I went okay great I talked to
all the guys and by the way in order to
make someone like that you need the
other guys right to say because I always
like to say you never beat anybody right
wrestling truly beat you the guy allows
you to beat him right right so all those
guys in that ring right there I'll
forever be grateful for them because
they allowed that to happen so I I win
the
match uh New Star is Born in the world
of pro wrestling this rookie kid Rocky
Mya this is the one 123 here that
wrestler's Gold Dust comes from a very
famous family that guy was amazing
remember him yeah he was amazing man the
whole Gold Dust thing was crazy so can
you pause that for a second like go back
to my hair so I didn't know look at this
pause I didn't know that I went to the
hair person who was backstage I said can
you give me something that's going to
make my hair like nice and like go down
and she gave me like a thing that made
it frizzy and then that's what you get
by the way just a [__] up haircut on
your
debut like luckily the people of New
York was like this we kind of like this
kid his haircut is really [__] up you
look like kid in
play look like the bigger version of
kiden play look at this look at that
thing [__] that's a solid foot above
your head
it's awful right this time the referee's
like hey get the [__] out of the ring
come on we got to show so you so well so
what go ahead no no go ahead well I was
gonna say so we win this match and
things are ascending the dream is coming
true like this is it man I finally feel
like this is what I was born to do and
man it's feeling so [__] good guys in
the locker room all everybody take me
under their wing there's some political
[__] that you always want to stay
away from I've always stayed away from
that but for the most part everybody's
supportive um because even though it's a
Cutthroat business backstage you still
need some guys you know who are going to
show you the
way so I W up becoming the youngest
Intercontinental
Champion uh beating Triple H or he let
me beat him right everything was doing
this so at that time this interesting
thing was happening in the world of pro
wrestling where it was fans were
cheering the heels m and anti-authority
[__] the
boss uh led by Stone Cold Steve Austin
giving everybody the bird [__] Vince
McMahon fans were loving that
gravitating towards this that guy drives
a pickup drug drinks a beer tells
everybody go [__] themselves uh now in
wrestling world that's supposed to be a
bad guy but now he's becoming a hero
then you have this kid who's 25 who's
coming
out here we go you know the [__] old
school and Vince and the company always
told me hey you can't smile enough I was
like what do you mean you go out you
smile I want to make sure everybody
knows you're grateful gratitude of
attitude I said no okay and it started
not to feel good to me because I said
well so you know these nights I'm
getting beat but I still want you to
smile
anyway so you have this thing happening
over here the rise of the Attitude Era
and then you have this kid who's just
smiling away everything is good even
when he [__] loses
and it would didn't it never felt right
to me here and
then fans started to
turn booing every night got to a point
dude going into my first WrestleMania
Chicago I'll never forget it every night
they were chanting Rocky socks whoa and
I and I had to smile through
it the bosses were telling me now you
got to smile no keep smiling ignore it
ignore it just ignore it if you're
paying your hard-earned money as a fan
even though this world is fiction and
it's not real um the best of the
wrestlers always came from a real place
so I was smiling away I get to
WrestleMania Chicago sold out Stone Cold
Steve Austin's on top in the main event
I'm defending my
title
WrestleMania 20,000 people start
chanting Rocky sucks so imagine that
you're a kid 25 years old you got the
belt on you pressure you're in there and
the guy who I was wrestling U the sultan
who's actually my cousin
Rishi uh from my S inside he had me in a
rear chin
lock whole Arena's chanting Rocky sucks
he's whispering to me don't listen to
him don't listen to him now I'm like
[__] this is my life now
right we get out of the match I go
backstage Vince looks at me and Pat and
just says I don't know what we did wrong
but we have to make a change I know what
that
means 2 days later I dro the belt to
somebody
else now I'm getting beat every night
getting beat every night and then I get
hurt I tear my PCL a wrestling guy named
Mick
Foley Now by this time it's May Vin says
H you take time off heal your knee I I
don't know what we did wrong or where we
went wrong but I we got to really figure
things out with you I don't know if this
is going to work out W yeah man and this
is 1997 summer of
97 now this you you'll appreciate this
part in
97 during that time while I was still
going out to LA and working out we were
crossing all the MMA
guys Pride just opened up in Japan so I
I was seeing all these MMA guys going
over to Pride you remember remember that
time right I think you might have been
with UFC at that time right yeah going
and at that time I was making
$150,000 wrestling 235 days a year so do
the math of that how much you're making
per match we start hearing hey these
guys over in Pride are making 250 350
500 and I thought then well [__] I don't
think I'm going to make it in WWE people
are booing me out of the Arenas I can't
be myself they're telling me to [__]
smile I don't want to [__] smile it's
not who I
am I start talking to Ken Shamrock at
that time who was wrestling with us I
run into Mark Kerr I start talking to
him he tell me a little bit about pride
and I have this idea in my head well
maybe I should maybe I should train to
MMA and go to Pride and make money real
money and then I don't have to
smile I'm sure I'm gonna get [__] up
over there and then knock one of my
lungs loose but maybe I could do
something like that find the right coach
and trained so I had this whole thing in
my head I was talking to my wife at that
time I said I think that's the way to go
cuz those guys are paying real money and
these fans are booing me over here for
Grand I get a call from Vince and he
says how's your knee I said it's healing
up I don't tell him about this idea
after I've talked to Shamrock and kerr
and all these
guys um he goes I want to try and bring
you back one time see how it works out I
want to turn you heel and we have a
faction called the nation of
domination who DC loves by the way that
was his famous his his favorite Daniel
uh the black militant group he goes I
want to have you join them and we'll see
how it works out I come in I said okay
but I still got this MMA thought in my
head again I just want to make money and
I want to be myself right when I get to
the arena that night I'm gonna join the
nation I went to Vince and at that time
there was only just two hours of live
show Monday Night Raw now there's six
hours of show on two different programs
so I said to Vince hey tonight when I go
out there could I just have two minutes
on the microphone and he's like uh I
don't know he goes it's live you know
all our times accounted for all
allocated I said I just need two minutes
he goes why I said I just want to be
real and just tell the fans how I feel
um and I feel like I I need to
recalibrate things here he said fine a
minute you got great get on on the
microphone now now I'm walking out
they're booing me rock G sucks but now
I'm a heel with this heel group I grab
the microphone and I say something like
listen I'm a lot of things but sucks
isn't one of them and joining the nation
isn't a white thing it's not a black
thing it's it's a me kicking your ass
thing and I'm G to earn this respect one
way or the
other dude that was the most freeing
thing for me in my career it was like
you know how you have these defining
moments even in that one little moment I
was just [__] ripping all this open M
say Here I Am you now you could [__]
boo me but now watch How I respond I'm
going to be real I didn't have to smile
anymore I don't [__] The Smiling I'll
smile when I want to smile right right
right but now watch Watch How I can
respond wh watch my words now watch my
actions dude the fans felt something
that night
within a month I became the hottest heel
in WWE
wow